Bane is the man who broke the bat an
individual capable of matching and even
surpassing Bruce Wayne in his willpower
physicality and strategy so it should
perhaps be no surprise that nearly all
of my videos on Batman trading also
surrounded by requests for a Bane
training series and what better time
than now to examine a character he
developed incredible physical power from
the confines of a prison cell
stuck in isolation just as many of us
are right now for those not familiar
with his story
Bane grew up in jail imprisoned for his
father's crimes despite having no access
to the myriad resources of Bruce Wayne
Bane developed his body in his mind
through rigorous training his own form
of meditation and as many books as he
could gain access to I had to plan to
make this video a few weeks ago but then
Jax blade dropped one on this exact
topic his is great and you should go and
check it out it has loads of ideas taken
straight from the comics so now I was
going to skip it but it's just too
perfect for the situation we're in right
now training in isolation and wearing
masks that make us all sound funny and
as it turns out I have some cool stuff
to add to the discussion so without
further ado its bane isolation training
so Bane is a fan favorite villain
because he's the perfect Walker
reflection of Bruce Wayne Bane's power
comes from the exact same place an
unbreakable will and a commitment to
bettering himself so true is this that
he forged himself into peak human
condition body and mind all without
leaving his four walls the awesome thing
is that we have plenty of real-world
precedent for this kind of training of
course one of the most famous examples
is Charles Bronson who wrote solitary
fitness real name Charles Salvador looks
like dr. Robotnik Bronson has written at
length about training methods that can
be utilized while in isolation
many of these revolve around the use of
unusual objects or high repetition
calisthenics Bronson brags that he can
lift an entire snooker table and perform
1727 press ups in an hour he claims that
he performed 2000 push-ups daily at one
point in a previous video I discussed
how high repetitions of bodyweight
exercise could be very effective for
developing strength but only when
performed to failure as closed chain
exercises the chance of injury is
relatively low even when going too
super-high rep range but at the same
time going to failure means that your
body is forced to utilize all the muscle
fiber involved in the movement once the
slow twitch muscle fibers fatigue there
is no choice but to engage the fast
twitch fibers and large motor units in
short lifting 10% of your 1 rep max
feels like 100 % of your warm rep max
once you're at knee 120 rep or in
Bronson's case the 1727 and the neural
adaptations will be similar at the same
time this can provide a huge buildup of
blood in the working muscles resulting
in significant hypertrophy not to
mention an increased blood supply for
enhanced recovery via newly created
capillaries this same strategy worked
for the Indian wrestle of gamma mu
legend has it would train using sets of
5000 Hindu squats and 3,000 Hindi
push-ups Bryson isn't the only guy to
resort to super high reps whilst in
isolation either another example is Mike
Tyson who reportedly used a similar
method to develop his massive legs
whilst in jail he would use massive sets
of squats to pick up and place down
cards I've heard different versions of
this routine some say 8 cards some say
10 but generally the challenge involves
creating taller and taller piles from
one side to the next by moving the cards
over one at a time this should be
performed quickly to allow a massive
hydrogen iron buildup and a real burn in
the legs when Tyson emerge from jail is
electric huge and this allowed him to
generate more power in his blows using
cars this way to make a potentially
mind-numbing workout more interesting is
apparently common in jail another
example is the deck of pain here you go
through a pack of cards one at the time
performing a different movement for each
suit and reps depending on the number of
reps so it's a kind of chaos trading
where you never know exactly what you're
gonna get dealt next this is an
interesting aspect of training and
isolation finding ways to keep the
training fresh and motivating without a
coach shouting in your ear or tunes
coming through your headphones it's a
form of gamification which is a great
strategy for anyone who struggles with
motivation when training body weight is
one obvious option when it comes to
training without gym access but there
are other options too for example
overcoming isometrics
I've discussed this topic before but
essentially the aim is to push or pull
against an immovable force by pushing
against a wall or pulling against the
tree which
by the way was another method used by
gamma it's possible to engage a hundred
percent of your strength as far as the
body is concerned it's the same as
trying to lift or pull more than 100
percent of your one rep maximum and once
again the body will adapt in the same
way increasing your mind muscle
connection and neural drive to help you
engage more muscle fiber and more
strength you may not see as much
hypertrophy due to the lower muscle
damage there's not really any eccentric
portion going on and the lack of full
range of motion might also mean the
strength gains aren't as great however
it also has unique advantages as there
is no strength curve to contend with
for example meaning that a hundred
percent effort is sustained for much
longer than in one rep max it's a great
supplement to strength training and if
you're in jail well then it might be all
you've got you need to do this at at
least three different joint angles
seeing as the area of effect is only
around 30 degrees holding threat for
about six seconds you can also use your
own body weight and this is something
I've been experimenting with lately for
example my earth crusher exercise we lie
on the ground and then essentially try
to PEC fly the earth in jail though you
might also use the bars of yourself this
according to stories is exactly what old
times strongman Alexander's ass aka the
amazing Samson did zas served in the
Russian military in World War one and
was placed in a prisoner of war camp the
story goes that he built up his strength
by pulling against the iron bars every
single day eventually he gained the
strength to bend those bars at that
point he promptly stepped out of his
jail window three he went on to use the
strength as a traveling strongman
breaking chains to wow audiences another
way that beign may have developed the
necessary willpower to port his powerful
body is through meditation I'll be
talking about this in another video that
meditation can strengthen and develop
the anterior cingulate cortex and the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex these
are brain regions that relate to focus
motivation and sustained attention which
makes sense things you're essentially
trying to concentrate on one thing such
as your breathing that's called a
directive meditation according to the
comics they not only mastered meditation
while in jail whatever that means but
also developed his own style of
meditation so it's a comic but I love
this we assume that things like
meditation a state could practices that
we can't tamper with but someone has to
push these concepts forwards and we're
all different so why not experiment with
your own techniques and come up with
something unique there
works for you one method that might
apply to someone like Bain would be to
use visualization to train the body and
the mind
for example this might mean playing
chess against an invisible opponent
according to the book the brain that
changes itself by Norman Doidge this is
how wrongfully imprisoned human rights
activist Anatoly Sharansky managed to
avoid going insane while in isolation
he played imaginary games of chess
against himself developing his skills
enough to eventually emerge and defeated
then world champion Garry Kasparov but
it's actually a known sport called
blindfold chess incredibly some experts
even play multiple games of blindfold
chess against real opponents
simultaneously memorizing multiple
boards and the positions of every single
chess piece maintaining that image in
their mind and then thinking
strategically about those boards one
player alexander alkyne is reported to
have played 26 simultaneous games
winning 16 drawing 5 and losing only 5
that's insane
Sherlock Holmes but pure game as far as
I'm concerned this shatters the notion
of a working memory that is limited to
seven plus or minus two digits it's
clearly far more multi-sensory than that
and not quite so straight forwards but
imagine the incredible strategizing
memory capacity to juggle information
that could be developed this way
similarly practicing mental maths could
also be a powerful tool in the same book
Deutsch describes how Hudak agam used
this same strategy to develop the skills
of a human calculator again this is
something I'm going to be talking about
more soon so stay tuned for that one of
course Bane was also driven by his
insane desire to destroy Batman this
gave him a central goal and a purpose
that put fire in his belly even before
he'd ever seen Batman this is something
that we can all learn from I'm not
recommending that you choose an
arch-nemesis and obsess about destroying
them but having a goal is key to self
determination find your passion and do
that and suddenly you can achieve
incredible things
so prevents video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
and share it around let me know if there
any other characters you'd like me to
analyze the training of and leave a
comment down below if we can think of
anything I missed out for training like
Bane in isolation let me know how you
guys are coping with your lockdown
workouts of course subscribe if you want
to see more like this
and if you like this alternative and
theoretical approach to training then
you'll probably enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training I'll leave a link to that in
the description down below and there's a
discount on at the moment whilst we're
all in lockdown hope you guys are all
staying safe and healthy and I'll see
you in the next one thanks a ton for
watching and bye for now